dites moi si je me trompe on l'est sur
un concept de coupe en glace à
l'italienne
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rené si le concept de coûts big bang
j'adore mais à dieu bénisse les chômeurs
c'est le gorec les casser mes potes de
haut niveau il ya des extra terrestres
parmi nous merci qui est franchement
mais il faut ni les énormes et nous
après le garde
qu'est ce qu'il ya écrit et j'ai retour
[Applaudissements]
on l'a perdu évidemment on a perdu un
moment
j'adorerais vous ferez bien les actions
du sud ou et que ça peut te [ __ ] des
intrus et cherché à me parler d'une
avance um avec l'accent du sud y ait des
machines qui faisaient pourtant tu fais
quoi la machine est bon donc c'est quoi
la magie des bouchons dans les oreilles
[Applaudissements]
sam rsa c'est complètement imprévue mais
mais mais on pouvait pas faire moins
rendent hommage touchant tous les deux
un but de plus deux écoutes bien ça dure
que madagascar isabelle tombe dans les
mains non non non non
mon collègue la barbade
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]